Michael is an art aficionado who loves
visiting galleries and sharing his
experiences with friends on social media
today Michael is embarking on a quick
vacation to Paris while waiting for his
plane he visits the Paris tourism
website and installs the site's map
application onto his iPhone there he is
able to sign in with his Twitter account
create a profile and select which
artists and galleries he has the most
interest in upon arriving in Paris
Michael receives a welcome notification
from the tourism mobile app IBM ODM
Advanced has detected his arrival and
after reviewing a few of his art
inspired Twitter posts offers access to
a predefined selection of modern art
events taking place all over the city in
the coming days
Michael is delighted at the curated
selection all the events match his
interests from the app and his Twitter
account Michael uses the selection to
locate a nearby museum featuring his
favorite artists the next morning IBM
ODM advanced detects he has not yet
attended any events in the last 24 hours
and sends him a special offer for that
museum on his phone allowing him to
bypass the long admission lines he
gladly attends and quickly finds
exciting new pieces meanwhile IBM odium
advance is notified by the ibeacon
feature of Michael's phone and peers the
information alongside his social media
data to suggest similar artists that are
only right down the hall
leaving the museum Michael is given one
last notification offering him VIP
access to a nearby art foundation if he
registers as a customer ecstatic he
signs up and is shocked to find a pass
ready at his arrival he takes pictures
of his favorite pieces and posts some to
Twitter sharing how much he enjoyed
visiting the foundation the pictures he
posts receive tremendous activity
fostering positive engagement towards
the museums as well as the tourism app
he visits the foundation store before he
leaves and eagerly purchases a print IBM
odium advanced has recognized his tweets
and their positive sentiment and awards
him for being an advocate with the help
of the tourist app empowered by IBM ODM
Advanced Michael was able to maximize
his short stay in the city and visit
places tailored to his tastes the app
uses IBM odium advanced to leverage
Twitter and geospatial data to build and
maintain context developing insights
about Michael that could be acted upon
in near real-time with personalized
offers ultimately Michael leaves Paris
happy and eager to return